hello i ronaldo bom você e não estava
vai ficar agora porque o doce chegou eu
tinha que comemorar que nosso canal
completou mais milhões de inscritos
para mim eu estava almoçando me que
tinha de frango agora o filho não se
fica feito tem que comer frango que o
fraga conhecer como você fala meu deus
por que que eu comi outra coisa na vida
eu vou começo resto da minha vida eu pra
quem não come x-burguer basta duas
semanas não aguenta mais de frango meu
do chão escuto galo cantar o cubo come
frango feeds e acaba com a grande
oficial do frango falar a verdade na
cabeça e metade tem alguém que como
alguém há sempre corre do leão o frango
corda a gracyanne barbosa e laís troca
felipe franco juros alimentando ele como
funk eu acho que a gente nem as penas
que o freguês igual tão ingênua na boca
não é só se sai caminhando e o frango
vivo a eu morrer agora vai prejudicar
uma pessoa muito especial entrevistado
de hoje é o lógico que você deixa esse
vídeo a click conceito é muito
importante toda vez que você clique
gostei do youtube entende que você quer
receber ou nos vídeos e aí você recebe
notificação bom então já que gostei que
o assunto era nem eu queria falar com
você escreva na outra coisa ia falar
sobre viagem porque assim eu faço o meu
show e no meu choro eu viajo muito e eu
conto sobre as viagens também não amo
viajar o mundo inteiro esse sempre foi
meu sonho é o trabalho em função de ter
dinheiro para viajar mais o resto da
minha vida inteira e conhecer todo mundo
é você o mundo tem país que só porque eu
só conheci 30 até agora eu vou falar com
vocês um mundo é todo o mundo
quando eu viajo coopers passagem da max
milhas a a aaron rodgers passo em favor
do careiro chegam papéis de graça pra
cima de mim conta de humberto todo mundo
sabe que você ganha mais
ae só de fato eu tenho mas meus amigos
não eu só viagem com deus amigo que tudo
comigo é bem melhor que eto o que era
apenas amigo agora tocava na perna com
um amigo meu foi do irã foi mais dele
depois mas o tempo se fala de ferro ou
[ __ ] disso quebrou a perna no
acampamento e cartão só viaja com meus
amigos meus amigo isso mas lhes do que
uma lesma de um pode manter então eu
quero viajar com meus amigos tenho que
comprar só do homem roubar comprar um
monte de passagem de cargas em que tem a
máquina e às vezes são as passagens com
mais ou menos 80% de desconto e só nessa
passagem barata e meu melhor fui pra
cada um gato é doido mas não fui para a
irlanda irlanda o sinistro qual é o rumo
da iv semana da [ __ ] vai voando eu vou
dizer macho peguei a br 10
mais direto eu não sei nunca pensei foi
que a irlanda casa sem saber o inglês
não tem mensagem jogar falei está tudo
certo eu chegava para diz não tá tudo
certo chega lá no aeroporto o transfer
matching espera é valley aí no trânsito
na externa e nem cheguei lá o cara tava
lá eu e aí transferir a irmã eu pensava
que era o nome do cara quer selar a dona
de transfer toque mágoa tem muito
brasileiro elano por que todo brasileiro
que está em pauta é bom né que eu postei
brasileiro todo mundo entrou vou
conseguir informação alguma coisa boa
agora pra mim que sou um artista
diferente que eu quero a irlanda eu
quero casar eu cheguei na irlanda
ninguém vai me conhecer vou tomar todas
as cachaças invocado meio fio com o
cachorro lambendo mil anos eu entro no
bar mas o ano o que é muito brasileiro
eu iria falar mais com a casa do a
pessoa traga me completava a rede seja
mais vontade de tomar a
o meu foi incrível mas chegou o meu pai
minha mãe o sonho de levar meu pai para
conhecer que ela sabia clarinha quero
também fazer casag não parece também
aquelas água transparente longe é longe
e quer saber porque todo mundo haviam
tome que tratem dos castelos mãe gritava
ficava me muito a mão à cabeça de mãe
que não tem como tirar onde ela entrava
aheta o casal baixíssima e com mamãe pro
mãe mãe já passou e se mãe pelo amor de
deus muito a cabeça de mãe que tudo que
ela vê cair ela quer levantar tudo que
ela fez a mala do carro mas sei que isso
não é de todo o tempo por causa de copa
já que a água se não tomar gol não falar
muito porque se você tomar toda água que
vão oferecer mas pude chega um momento
que tem que criar as respostas que
existem cargos não levaram não beba água
não quer ver já diz não sou evangélico
deus me livre após manga mágoa de não
tomar o leite passa o perigo é uma mãe
coração de cinco anos do brasil e uma
mãe mãe é três a diferença toda hora que
for que espera a volta treinar frente
mas na hora do brasil todo o tempo ea
hora que eu pegava ela começa no celular
zé mulheres de cor ou será que deu uma
volta que já são quatro até agora são
erdan apólonia gente foi uma vez na
polônia na polônia nós pegamos um frio
de menos 13 graus veja bem o menino do
piauí na cidade de bom jesus que já foi
eleita 21 vezes a cidade mais quente do
pai vítima joão urubu salvar uma carniça
se morrer debaixo de uma árvore de
button armazém morreu a vaca na falta ou
favor do mato respeitando ele tem uma
meia vida pedi que ela me disse 'vamos
em uma farmácia comprar o remédio agora
condicionado de repente eu me vejo na
polônia com menos 13 graus centígrados
ué sentido do sul aceite grupo pois
sente gravosas lhes menos três graus
celsius portiolli atesta que começa a
ficar madura seu nariz cara que eu
pegava eu não sentia eu chegava para
repensar a chuva dá um pisão sentir
faltar dois a língua portuguesa 12 foram
em jogadas parecidas cachorro brigando
tá aí o a comida o amar louca que eu já
acho prato chegar porque fala o que é
isso aqui era um prato que o nome do
prato vencer não só de si para não se
aquilo é para gente é exatamente por
isso que eu gosto de viajar você comia e
era bom que a gente cresce igual a gente
como sempre a mesma coisa a gente acha
que esse é o jeito certo de comer você
vai em outro país conseguir mexer com as
coisa e conhece outro paris pouco
aparece que todo mundo mas fui pra mim
porque vale o lecce que é o meu sonho é
conhecer a torre o empresário cheguei
parecer no sentido de se sentir mais uma
calma paciência papai posso brincar no
pan e os pais rolando foi pode brincar
no paa menino corre e choraram é o e
pintar um quadro mosca em paris eu vi
uma duas e essa mesmo muito educado não
sentava na gente achava que exige olhar
na minha cara banjo passava não aceitava
qualquer lixo sincero mas somos educados
eu vi uma criança com um cachorrinho
falar olha quem passava no caso minha
criança pode pagar esse cantor laser de
alta está me incomodando tanto vai
chegar a licença campanha você não pode
sentar nesse banco continuar jornal
criado e camponeses lento
chega de gea a comida se olhava o nome
ainda vai deixá la plata foi campeão
goiano voltou a sair eu vi aquele nó
[ __ ] o país da frança francês nomes nem
mesmo esse deve ser um carro a emal para
trouxe uma agulha primeiros pão que eles
gostem da os pontos em que há pão na
barriga jeito nenhum eu só espero que
ela traga o pânico não não quero pão
doce aguentar web esbarrei no qual caiu
quebrou de adaptação à minha mulher e eu
falei [ __ ] que pariu o amor o [ __ ]
quebrou a páscoa o restaurante eu sei
nem dizer pedir desculpa
dom antônio bandeira nato o piado
lembrou é capaz de ver o cara sorrindo
ao do wii
já estava feliz we love eu pratico um
prato deixou eu falei hoje eu vou
arregaça na parede 30 graus é quando o
bota o prato os 4 carol sim de feijão
não o pedaço de um rápido beijo que eu
acho que não gostaria de jogar mas a
família já vi isso lá tocou ontem eu
atendi amanhã diz fala mãe foi a onde
parei de comer aqui no japão a comida é
muito só por bares é que ora são aí
mamãe eu comi pedir a conta vai ver o
cara com a conta do olhar canto 200
dólares lei valer não me prendo leva à
mesa não quer só comida minho que então
esse feijão é do jogo para o feijão vou
plantar vai subir roxa a mina de ouro
que tem um som e capotou para comandar o
olhar comando estava lá o corpo que
tinha quebrado a a abrandar um copo
never leza eu tenho que pagar um copo
cavalo e eu falei então se eu pago um
copo copa é meio né e técnica nem foi
tão juntos caso do copos do que eu vou
levar não tô pagando um copo agora vai
virar o copo seu povo só você vai deixar
só para agora a viagem da índia foi a
que eu voltei mais evoluído
espiritualmente na minha vida que foi
[ __ ] foi cara também graças a deus que
tinha mais milhas e às vezes a pessoa
estranha a opção para assim que o bicho
carros entram na pista 460 na bubu e era
3 mil conhece cai só pra onde ele está o
roubo é não chegou mais simples do
futebol aplicativo de pedir comida como
é que vai pedir como você tá em casa
quer comer e ter o restaurante popular
que vem mas que não vai lá vai ser fácil
vai aplicativo o aplicativo faz o que
une vocês dois
ele traz a comida pra você e ele faz a
conexão entre você 2 e o que acontece
não vai ganhar dinheiro eu vou pra
comida e você vai ter sua comida em casa
isso juntou só isso a china é a mesma
coisa tem gente que vieram para cá e vai
acumulando milhas e não viaja quem fim
no viagem e tem você quer viajar
só que você não quer juntar dois
o dinheiro para comprar a companhia no
céu onde você vai o que compra as milhas
de quem não tá usando as mídias acamados
- faz traz a comida do restaurante
bastante brincadeira humor que ela une
você quer viajar com a pessoa que tem
milhas e no uso entendeu e pega as
linhas da pessoa quando você começa a
sair mais barato eu acho legal também
eles são sinceros que você tem da
maxvinil se tiver mais caro do que na
companhia aérea disse chávez em um ato
em la plata a companhia aérea tam a
índia foi caála eo muito impactante
carro pra cá e carrega dhhp atrás dos
carros tem escrito buzine porque pra
eles buzzi não sei se localização
entendeu se tem gente buzinando que tem
visto a placa tem que tomar cuidado não
é como aqui quente buzina votar por teté
é posso tá sobrando língua certa
lá não tem 70 é é um mundo com o rh lado
há cintos entender todo mundo ansioso
pra você o meu deus até aí tudo bem até
que chegou o meu primeiro café da manhã
na ilha que era macarrão com frango
valer que macarrão de manhã agora e já
foi longe demais de grande não tava 5
grau gelado nominais e vai com a
impressão de que você vai funda cep
cheguei a pensar que o sonho do povo não
se cala de frio congelou ficou assim o
exige que para cá é um país com 1 bilhão
de pessoas cara que é muita gente toda
hora eu não sei quem foi que inventou
esse nome fila indiana e que nem fila
indiana onde ano não faz fila
fui visitar o monumento lá que a gente
toma fila para 300 pessoas do meu lar
300 batatas praça central sentindo
negócio contando a minha bunda que eu
virei pra dar um murro de olhei o bota
bota pessoal empurra eu vi que a culpa
não era dele chegou a concordar falar
assim mas sobre isso não gosto da minha
perna tá bossa falar ea língua deles é
diferente show pra baixo de lixo rotary
e do dri tudo é tanta que a pt tem nada
não passei da gente eu sei que me cortei
com ferro sem querer o que o rendimento
pedir para levar os que estão levando o
hospital foi lá eo médico marca coca
kakuta que tocará a agora que tá na hora
que está na parte de paquetá onde eu saí
muito aí foi que ele diz e disse papai
eu disse que vou morrer tudo tinha
pimenta tudo sorvete tinha primeiro e
dianteiro da van oord meu e da
meia-noite na mídia aqui no brasil me
ligava a proibir já está bom e que
cuidasse do meu espaço espaço para
domingo que a nação é inclusivo não fala
ainda do meu show das partes a galera
mais em loket com as coisas que eu falei
que o vídeo é óbvio mas que está no meu
show ontem 4 o último show acabar esse
ano em manaus é a lei manacapuru em
fortaleza ceará que eu vou gravar o
especial com o netflix meu show ingresso
nesse site aqui países se você gostou
clique gostei quando esquece se você
quiser viajar o mundo que nem eu e
barato é só uma trilha só recapitula
você não compra militar não precisa ter
milhas também vai comprar é só comprar
igual compra normal entender o que eles
fazem a conexão de quem tem milho
tocando muito barato igual a qualquer
site no instante chega no seu e-mail e
já pode fazer o chiquinho normal a todos
eu queria que você comentasse aqui em
baixo um história de viagem que você já
teve importa para onde foi esse foi o
valor foi para perto toda a viagem legal
[ __ ] mapito carro é que estou mais
calmo eu fui pra índia editado mas é
isso estamos junto é nóis valeu embu e